le bilan après l'attaque du Hamas sur
Israël continue de s'alourdir de façon
vertigineuse au 5e jour de l'attaque
surprise lancé par le mouvement
islamiste palestinien depuis Gaza on va
revenir sur ce qui s'est passé depuis
samedi grâce aux cartes du service
infographie du Figaro et pour en parler
je suis avec amori coutané bonjour amori
bonjour Vincent merci d'être avec nous
aujourd'hui hop on va enlever le son
tout de suite qui se vient de s'activer
on va parler de de de ce qui s passé
j'invite nos interes bien sûr à poser
leurs questions on y répond au mieux
comme d'habitude à Mori on va déjà
revenir sur ce qui s'est passé samedi
matin très tôt là-bas alors voilà
effectivement samedi matin vers à peu
près 6h du matin le Hamas donc c'est un
mouvement palestinien terroriste qui
règne sur la bande de Gaza depuis qu'il
a gagné des élections législatives il y
a plus de 15 ans maintenant a fait une
percé en fait ils ont ils sont rentrés
par la barrière de sécurité israélienne
que tout le monde pensait
infranchissable il faut quand même
imaginer que ça coûtait 1 milliard de
dollars quasiment qu'il y a des murs de
béton qu'il y a des barbelets un système
dernier CR et cetera et ils ont réussi à
franchir cette barrière de sécurité ils
en ont détruit une partie à plusieurs
endroits ils sont rentrés et ils ont
commis des massacres enlever des civils
tuer des gens jusque à plusieurs
dizaines de kilomètres à l'intérieur du
territoire israélien à une dizaine de
kilomètres pardon ils ont donc enlevé
alors les chiffres ne sont pas encore
certains mais on peut estimer que c'est
aux alentours de 100 entre 100 et 1005
civils israéliens qui ont été emmenés
dans la bande de Gaza à l'heure où nous
parlons et le bilan ne peut que
s'alourdir c'est ce que disait ce matin
le porte-parole de l'armée israélienne
on déplore 1200 morts et il y a déjà 169
soldats de tsal l'armée israélienne qui
sont morts au combat contre ce mouvement
palestinien effectivement et on le voit
sur cette carte vous pouvez voir ce ce
qu'il s'est passé donc ce qui est en
vert c'est la bande de Gaza on se trouve
là au sud du pays c'est ça ça fait à peu
près trois fois Paris pour nous donner
une un ordre d'idée et il y a a 2 vir
entre 2,2 et 2,3 millions d'habitants
qui sont donc extrêmement concentrés au
allons entre 700 et 800000 personnes
habitent dans la ville de Gaza seul donc
on imagine l'environnement urbain
extrêmement dense on pourra en reparler
sans doute tout à l'heure mais pour
conduire une opération militaire ça sera
vraiment extrêmement compliqué on voit
également sur votre carte qui est écrit
rave party donc il y avait un un
festival de musique électronique qui se
déroulait donc vous voyez à peu près à à
8 km environ de la frontière de la bande
de gaz voilà à volold d'oiseo et donc là
il faut imaginer il y a une très belle
enquête vidéo du Wall Street Journal
soyons bon camarade avec avec les
journalistes américains qui ont montré
voilà l'enquête c'est-à-dire que aux
alentours de 6h car il y a des premières
roquettes qui sont arrivées qui ont
survoler le festival les gens ne
savaient pas trop c'était des jeunes et
cetera faut vraiment imaginer 6h15 du
matin on est dans un festival un samedi
et et progressivement ils ont commencé
un peu à paniquer à partir et en fait
les les les gens du Hamas ont bloqué la
route de par et d'autrre du parking et
en fait on ont tué ont tué tout le monde
environ 200 personnes à l'heure où nous
parlons et ont enlevé tout un tas de de
de civils qu'ils ont emmené vers la
bande de Gaza dont cette fameuse jeune
femme que l'on voit conduite sur une
moto par des terroristes du Hamas alors
est-ce qu'on peut montrer les les les
les endroit on le disait il y avait une
barrière qui était une barrière avait un
mur qui était là alors sur des images on
voit un bulldoer passer on a
l'impression que c'est on nous a dit que
c'était sécurisé vous dit un milliard on
a l'impression qu'un simple bulldozer
peut passer ça finalement alors voilà il
faut imaginer que la la barrière n'est
pas uniforme on le voit effectivement ça
entoure toute la frontière terrestre de
la bande de Gazin euh donc il y a
effectivement par endroit des murs qui
sont de plusieurs plusieurs mètres qui
sont vraiment des murs de béton
extrêmement solides mais à d'autres
endroits il y a des des points de de
passage avec des barrières et cetera et
enfin à d'autres endroits il y a
seulement des des des murs de barbelet
qui semblaient extrêmement euh fort
extrêmement solide mais qu'effectivement
on a pu voir on a pu voir sur certaines
images que un tractopel le propulse euh
et a réussi à les détruire ce qu'il
s'est passé en fait il y a plusieurs
choses dans plusieurs endroits
c'est-à-dire que à certains endroits il
y a eu euh des des des roquettes qui ont
été envoyées puis euh des explosifs qui
ont été posés et qui ont permis de créer
une brêche par lesquelles les militants
du amas donc se sont engouffrés au cours
dequel ils se sont engouffrés à d'autres
endroits ils ont franchi tout simplement
des postes frontières en tuant les
militaire israélien qui était là pour la
sécurité oui parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
de de comment dire de de de post
frontière justement il y a beaucoup de
de de de Checkpoint qui servent en fait
pour que tal vienne faire des opérations
alors soit viennent faire des opérations
soit dans certains cas il y a des gens
qui travaillent dans la bande de Gaza
alors c'est toujours voilà un jeu de
ping-pong entre le Hamas et le
gouvernement israélien pour savoir
combien de personnes pourront travailler
c'est quand même une partie non
négligeable de de l'économie et donc à
certains endroits sous conditions de
permis de fout de sécurité extrêmement
sévère et certains Gazaoui pouvaient
pendant un certain temps passer un poste
frontière et aller travailler en
territoire israélien il y a également un
un poste frontière que l'on voit au
niveau du V de de Vincent Roson dessus
qui a un poste frontière décalé un peu
du coup voilà qui a un poste un poste
qui est à la frontière avec avec
l'Égypte le le gouvernement israélien
Benjamin Netanyahou a prévenu que la
riposte israélienne serait très forte et
donc a invité les civils Gazaoui à
s'enfuir et un certain nombre ont
commencer à se diriger naturellement
vers ce ce poste au frontières dans
l'espoir de pouvoir se réfugier en
Égypte mais l'Égypte a dit hier qui qui
n'accepterait pas un exode massif selon
les propres mots de Palestiniens pour
revenir au au poste frontière à la
manière dont ils sont détruits c'est
vraiment l'une des c'est l'une des
surprises de ce qui s'est passé samedi
matin tout le monde pensait que c'était
vraiment une technologie de dernier cri
et force force de constater que le Hamas
sétait vraiment bien entraîné on a pu
voir des vidéos de propagande qui ont
été publiées plus récemment il s'était
vraiment entraîné la manière dont se
positionné pour échapper à la
surveillance pourtant vigilante des des
des des gardes israélien qu'ils ont
réussi à tuer puis à passer à d'autres
endroits où en fait ils ont juste foncé
dans le tas et et l'armée israélienne a
été submergée par le nombre il faut
imaginer voilà qu'il y a vraiment
énormément de de de de miliciens qui
sont arrivés on estime que près de 1500
auraient été ont déjà d'ors et déjà
été abattu effectivement sur le
territoire israélien on ne connaît pas
exactement le nombre à date total de
miliciens qui sont qui sont intervenus
mais on peut imaginer que c'était
colossal et encore une fois il faut
imaginer la rapidité avec lesquel ça
s'est passé et la COORDIN c'estàd qu'il
y a donc des roquettes qui ont été
lancées donc le dô de fer ce système de
défense anti-aérien israélien s'est mise
en système pour abattre les roquette et
en parallèle de ça il y a eu
effectivement ces fameuses images avec
le tractopel et donc voilà des des
convois de de de de militants
terroristes qui sont rentrés à plusieurs
endroits pour aller commettre des
atrocités un peu partout sur le
territoire israélien effectivement on
l'a vu il y a le ce d de fer on le dit
il est en place depuis un moment quand
il y a un des missile qui part de Gaza
il Inter on estime sa fiabilité à peu
près 90 % des des roquetes là le but ce
qui s'est passé c'est d'arriver à le
faire euh de le surcharger finalement de
tirer tellement de roquettes qu' pouvit
rien faire c'est ça exactement
exactement exactement l'idée c'est
vraiment de de de de consteller le le le
ciel de de Rocket afin que le système
soit vraiment submergé c'est un peu la
même chose que on en avait déjà
d'ailleurs parlé ici une méthode
qu'avait utilisé les Russes en Ukraine
pendant un moment c'est-à-dire lancer
énormément de drones de façon à ce que
la défense anti-ienne soit submergée par
le nombre et c'est en partie s'est passé
et il faut surtout imaginer que des
roquettes comme ceela c'est plusieurs
milliers de dollars voire parfois
quelques centaines alors que une
roquette du D de fer c'est environ 30000
dollars donc on peut imaginer également
le le prix que représente l'entretien
d'un tel système alors les Israéliens
sont assez fiers ils ont présenté ça
depuis quelques mois d'un système laser
dont Didier Leroi a pu parler d'ailleurs
dans une dans un entretien pour Le
Figaro un système laser qui coûterait
environ 5 dollars et qui permettrait
d'intercepter une roquette en en enfin
voilà en la ciblant et et la roquette
tombera et explosera au sol oui parce
que ces roquettes elles sont tombées pas
seulement à quelques kilomètres elles
sont aussi parties bien plus loin
effectivement alors on peut le voir sur
la carte jusqu'à hkellon et et un peu
plus loin même HDT que l'on voit voilà
effectivement au nord au nord de de de
notre carart donc il faut imaginer que
voilà il y a à peu
près une grosse vingtaine de kilomètres
à peu près 30 km depuis le nord de la
bande de gazage jusqu'à jdod adod voilà
c'est une ville de de 40000 habitants si
si je ne dis pas de bêtises donc voilà
c'est vraiment des gens qui habitaient
qui vivaient normalement en début de
weekend et qui en se réveillant ont
découvert des roquettes qui sont tombées
dans leur jardin alors ça c'est pour la
partie bande de Gaza qu'on regarde depis
mais il y a d'autres questions qui vont
se poser maintenant il y a plus d'autres
endroits notamment au sud du Liban donc
là au sud au sud du Liban et donc au
nord d'Israël là là on montrait ce qui
se passait au niveau au au sud d'Israël
donc la bande de Gaza si on remonte à la
frontière nord d'Israël on se trouve
face au Liban et là aussi il y a eu des
des tirs absolument alors juste pour
remettre peut-être un peu dans le
contexte on voit hchuré sur votre carte
le plateau du Golan le plateau du Golan
donc c'est une hauteur qui domine la
plaine syrienne de l'autre côté et la
plaine naturellement israélienne de
l'autre et qui a été conquise qui a été
conquis par Israël pendant la guerre des
6 Jours en 1967 et qui avait la raison
pour laquelle le le plateau du Golen a
été conquis c'est parce que Israël argit
que certains terroristes euh lancai des
roquettes depuis le plateau sur la
plaine israélienne donc ils ont été
conquis et en jaune on peut voir c'est
une zone conté contestée que l'on
appelle les fermes de Chebaa voilà donc
on a on a on a cette zone-là et au sud
du Liban il faut imaginer qu'il y a un
groupe qui s'appelle le hzbollah qui est
effectivement aussi un parti politique
au Liban et qui a une branche armée qui
est qualifiée de terrorise par un
certain nombre d'institutions
international et de pays dont les
États-Unis euh ses membres du hbola sont
farouchement anti-israélien Israël avait
mené une guerre contre elle en en 2006
au au sud du Liban on estime alors à
nasrala qui est le chef de du du
Hezbollah annoncé avoir disposé de
100000 combattants c'est sans doute
probablement exagéré la plupart des
analystes table pour autour de 25000
combattants réguliers mais auquel
s'agglomère un certain nombre de de
réservistes si j'ose le terme c'estàdire
de gens qui ont une cash niicov chez eux
et qui viennent enfiler unif voilà qui
pourrai venir et et donner un coup de
main le cas échéant alors le Hezbolla
est un ennemi d'Israël il est soutenu
par l'Iran qui est donc le le voilà le
l'ennemi géopolitique d'Israël au
Moyen-Orient
et beaucoup s'interrogeaient sur la
position qu'aurait le hzbola est-ce que
le hzbola attaquerait Israël
soutiendrait le Hamas est-ce que il y
aurait deux fronts et cetera ce qui
s'est passé c'est que le hezbola a tout
de même évidemment féliciter le Hamas
qui est son son allié finalement dans
cette lutte contre Israël mais n'atiré
que quelques roquettes quelques quelques
tirs d'artillerie qui ont été échangés
ce qui finalement est plutôt assez
monnaie courante dans cette dans cette
cette Rion R où vous en parlez sur la
zone en jaune qui qui qui est contextée
c'est un endroit où il y a souvent des
roquettes qui tombent absolument et donc
il faut imaginer qu'il y a des bases
israéliennes et qui ont été bombardé
donc par des positions du hzbollah qui
l'a revendiqué d'ailleurs mais le hzbola
très étrangement se sont demandé de
nombreuses personnes n'a pas envoyé de
troupe au sol en revanche et on
reviendra sur le hbola après en revanche
il y a eu des infiltrations de la part
du Djihad islamique le Djihad islamique
c'est une autre faction palestinienne
qui est éalement sise à Gaza mais qui a
une une partie de de ces troupes si je
puis dire au Liban qui ont tâché qui ont
essayé de s'infiltrer et qui ont été
abatttu par les forces de sécurité
israéliennes en revanche le hzbola n'a
pas envoyé en tout cas pour le moment ne
soyons pas présenteux pour le moment n'a
pas envoyé de troupe il y a probablement
deux raisons à cela la première c'est
une raison économique il faut imaginer
tout de même que le Liban est
complètement exangle depuis au moins
2019 que voilà l'économie va vraiment
très mal que les capitaux se sont enfuis
et qu'il y a 6 mois mois à peu près en
mars dernier il y a eu un accord de
réconciliation entre l'Arabie Saoudite
et l'Iran sous lesgide de la Chine qui a
fait espérer au Liban le retour des fond
de capitaux du golf qui réinjecterait un
certain nombre d'argent dans l'économie
libyanaise et qui aurait permis un
nouvel espoir
économique le hzbola s'est dit la moitié
du pays est divisé sur la question
palestinienne si je dois intervenir
alors qu'on commence à retrouver un
espoir économique je vais devoir me
battre contre Israël et la moitié de la
population libanaise va va vraiment me
détester parce que naturelle Israël
détruira un certain nombre
d'infrastructures qui sont essentielles
et nécessaires à cette reprise
économique en revanche je pense que le
l'état major du haszbola scrute avec
extrêmement d'attention ce qui ce qui se
passe effectivement dans la bande de
Gaza mais également dans les territoire
palestinien de 6 Jordanie et se dit si
jamais il y a une une insurrection
générale à laquelle d'ailleurs a appelé
le le Hamas en 6 Jordanie et ben il y
aura plusieurs fronts pourquoi ne pas en
profiter pour porter un coup encore plus
rude à à Israël mais c'est vrai que pour
le hzbola malgré son arsenal qui est
probablement l'un des plus puissants de
des milices qui sont développés au
Moyen-Orient c'est vraiment prendre des
coups avec un gain à espérer qui serait
assez minime bien bien supérieur en plus
ses moyens sont bien supérieurs à ceux
du Hamas par absolument il faut imaginer
que que le enfin je veux dire le hzbola
possède des chars des véhicules blindés
assez performants ils en font d'ailleurs
souvent état enfin pas souvent mais
régulièrement étint dans dans des
manifestations dans des défilés
militaires et ce
et le le le Hamas cependant possède des
armes de manufacture iranienne parce
qu'elle est soutenue comme le hzbola par
l'Iran et des armes de facture locale
Gazaoui effectivement donc on voit on
voit voit cette carte on comprend je
voulais en montrer une autre maintenant
c'est celle de la 6 Jordanie que je vais
vous afficher ici est-ce que on peut
expliquer à no internautes pourquoi
pourquoi cette carte est de différentes
couleurs comme celle-ci alors bien sûr
alors il faut il faut remonter aux
accords d'Oslo dans les années 90 qui
ont divisé la 6 Jordanie donc toute la
partie qui est colorée de la carte la
6jordanie si on se rappelle c'est en
après la guerre de 1948 avait été
conquise par la Jordanie voisine
administrée par la Jordanie et après la
guerre des 6 Jours en 1967 Israël avait
conquis cette région ainsi que
d'ailleurs Gaza le golane et cetera et
cette région étit donc sous
administration israélienne néanmoins les
Palestiniens qui vivaient avaient
absolument n'avait pas du tout les mêmes
droits naturellement que enfin
naturellement que les que les Israéliens
les accords deos slow on ont prévu donc
de diviser 7 6 Jordanie
entre un contrôle direct de l'Autorité
palestinienne c'est-à-dire un
gouvernement israélien c'est ce que l'on
voit en bleu foncé elle est sise à
ramala d'ailleurs voilà on peut voir sur
sur la carte il y a plusieurs grandes
villes donc naplous ramala Hébron que
l'on peut que l'on peut voir le bleu
ciel c'est ce que l'on appelle la zone B
donc c'est une zone mixte c'est-à-dire
qu'elle les affaires civiles ville si je
peux dire euh écho échoit à l'Autorité
palestinienne en revanche la sécurité
est gérée par Israël et toute la zone
jaune est gérée complètement par Israël
et c'est là où se trouve la plupart
aujourd'hui des colonies israéliennes et
et c'est la raison pour laquel à Gaza
peut-être il n'y avait pas assez de
personne pour pour assurer la sécurité
parce que c'est c'était ça le point le
plus chaud ce que pensait en tout cas le
gouvernement le point le plus chaud
était ici voilà et en plus alors on voit
la ville de Ouara euh sur sur notre
carte il faut imaginer d'ailleurs un
très bon reportage de notre
correspondant Guillaume de dieuleveu en
Israël en parlait très bien il y a une
route qui s'appelle la route 60 al c'est
c'est c'est justement c c cette route
qui est en rouge ici voilà qui part
effectivement voilà qui part du Nord et
qui va quasiment jusqu'au jusqu'au
jusqu'au sud voilà qui passe par
Jérusalem et qui va qui traverse
vraiment la S Jordanie de de de part en
part et en fait les les colons qui habit
dans ces régionsl devaient prendre cette
routes des travaux sont en cours mais
devaient traverser ce village duara et
était régulièrement la cible des des
Palestiniens il y avait des troubles un
peu partout à génine qui est un camp de
réfugié très important des Palestiniens
aujourd'hui qui a un foyer véritablement
de mouvement islamiste palestinien et
donc l'armée israélienne avait
concentrer un certain nombre de moyens
dans cette régionlà de façon à prévenir
les attaques à la fois contre les colons
mais aussi pour défendre ses intérêts
dans dans cette région il faut également
se rappeler qu'en 2020 il y a eu les
accords d'Abraham qui ont signé des
accords de normalisation
entre Israël et plusieurs pays dans
lesat Arabes Unis le Soudan non pas
encore l'Arabie Saoudite le Maroc et la
raison pour laquelle ces paysl on ont
signé c'était la non annexion si je puis
dire des zonees que l'on voit en jaune
donc des zones de la zone C par Israël
c'estàdire le fait que la loi
israélienne ne va pas s'appliquer sur
ces territoires là néanmoins on peut
penser qu'une certaine partie du
gouvernement israélien qui est de droite
voir d'extrême droite voir de droite rel
religieuse sioniste religieus et qui eux
souhaitent développer énormément ses
colonies y appliquer la loi israélienne
et finalement appliquer ce slogan d'un
certain nombre d'entre eux c'està-d un
pays de la rivière donc le Jourdain qui
est tout à droite que l'on voit à la mer
Méditerranée voilà donc pour comprendre
un peu ce qui se passe de ce côté-là au
niveau de la de de la sisjordanie on
peut repartir maintenant sur ce qui se
passe à la bande de Gaza on va même
regarder des images en
direct de de ce qui s'y passe c'est les
bombardements aujourd'hui euh c'est ce
qui c'est c'est ce qui arrive maintenant
Israël continue de bombarder la bande de
Gaza sans relâche voilà il faut
Imagineer que euh euh les forces armées
israéliennes jusqu'à encore très tôt ce
matin selon le encore une fois ce que ce
qu'a annoncé le porte-parole de l'armée
israélienne a repris la totalité des
localités qui avaient été prises par le
Hamas ou des atrocités pour la plupart
ont été perpétrées en tout cas on en
découvre encore aujourd'hui comme
karazza un kibuts ou même des enfants et
ont été assassinés on voyait le général
hier de division qui disait voilà moi ça
fait plus de 30 ans que je suis dans
l'armée j'ai fait de guerre et je n'ai
jamais vu de choses aussi horribles donc
on peut vraiment imaginer l'horreur de
ce qui s'est passé là-bas et l'armée
israélienne donc a repris
progressivement toutes ses positions a
encerclé toute la bande de Gaza
d'ailleurs le gouvernement a a dit
qu'elle allait assiéger la bande de Gaza
et ça veut bien dire ce que ça veut dire
c'est-à-dire que on dispose des pièces
d'artillerie et des soldats et de
l'infanterie et et des brigades
mécanisées tout autour de la bande de
Gazin l'eau a été coupée l'électricité a
été coupée donc vraiment on fait un
siège pur et dur en attendant ce que
l'on ce que l'on voit quasiment depuis
quelques heures après les l'entrée du
Hamas dans dans Israël ce sont des
campagnes aériennes le renseignement
israélien a identifié certains sites
soit de fabrication d'armes soit de de
quartiers généraux du Hamas et cetera et
ces sites ont été frappés par l'aviation
ou par des missiles israéliens des très
précis et ils le sont encore et la
question que tout le monde se pose c'est
les Israéliens vont-ils intervenir ir
militairement au sol vont-ils envoyer
des soldats au corps à corps contre les
militants du Hamas il faut imaginer bien
sûr que l'avantage de l'armée
israélienne c'est sa supériorité
technologique absolue je veux dire c'est
un pays qui a des avions de 5e
génération des F35 américains c'est des
avions absolument exceptionnel qui sont
capables de faire tout un tas de mission
et de bombarder comme on peut le voir
sur vos images et ils sont protégés
derrière cette supériorité technologique
mais à partir du moment où vous entrez
dans un environnement urbain dense comme
on en parlait tout à l'heure il y a une
sorte de de de caractère égalisateur
finalement c'est c'est vraiment d'homme
à homme si vous rentrez dans des
tranchées ou dans des rues étroites
malgré toute la technologie militaire
que vous avez finalement si le type en
face de vous a une arme est plus rapide
que vous vous pouvez mourir oui parce
que c'est de la guerriade enfin c'est gu
qui se en place absolument c'est c'est
voilà c'est de la guerria absolument et
c'est et les Israéliens vont devoir
faire de la la contreinsurrection
urbaine c'est c'est quelque chose
d'extrêmement difficile les armées
occidentales s entraîne régulièrement
mais c'est vraiment quelque chose de
très difficile et on en moyenne on
explique que pour faire un siège et êre
victorieux il faut 6 à hommes pour un
défenseur donc c'est vraiment un
ratio enfin énorme d'autant que là on
voit ce qui se passe à l'extérieur ce
qui se passe en plein air mais il a
aussi tout une galerie de souterrain
justement à Gaza et qui et qui change
aussi la donne et encore une fois on l'a
pas encore abordé mais il y a la
question des otages le gouvernement
israélien fait face à plusieurs options
qui sont toutes très mauvaise entrer
dans Gaza et et vraiment bombarder le
plus possible en créant probablement
énormément de victimes civiles c'est
s'exposer à la fois l'eauprre de la
communauté internationale probablement
une réprobation américaine et au
meurtrre en direct des otages qui ont
été pris ne pas répliquer ces se enfin
c'est se mettre en porte àfu avec son
opinion qui réclame bien sûr une des
représailles après cela et imaginez
envoyer des forces spéciales par exemple
conduire des opérations dans ses
souterrains pour aller chercher les
otages c'est extrêmement risqué parce
qu'encore une fois dans les souterrains
ils sont probablement minés euh c'est
encore une fois d'homme à homme de corps
à corps donc il faut avoir une
supériorité numérique et encore on n
même pas certain que ça suffise le le la
probabilité de retrouver des otages dans
de telles opérations est quand même
assez dangereuse assez faible et va se
poser au gouvernement israélien la
question de comment pouvons-nous
récupérer ces otages et à quel prix
sommes-nous prêts à conduire cette
opération militaire oui c'est c'est ça
qui va se poser parce que on sent que
c'est quand même une opération qui
semble euh pas poué à l'échec mais mais
pas loin on a l'impression extrêmement
difficile dans tous les cas c'est-à-dire
que il faut imaginer que tout ce qui est
au nord si on coupe à peu près la bande
de Gazin en de tout ce qui est au nord
est extrêmement urbanisé mais vraiment
très dense au sud c'est et un peu plus
c'est moins urbanisé c'est quand même
assez dense mais on peut imaginer des
des des des PL enfin pas des plaines
mais des terrains ouverts dans lesquels
des mouvements par exemple d'artillerie
ou de blindé sont beaucoup plus faciles
en revanche à partir du moment où vous
entrez
gaz dans le nord de Gaza c'est très
compliqué là toutes les frappes qui sont
en train d'être menées créent
naturellement des débris qui sont qui
jonchent le sol à partir du moment où on
envoie des blindés ces débris seront
probablement minés c'est extrêmement
difficile d'avancer avec des blindés ce
que disaient certains experts ce matin
c'est on peut imaginer envoyer des chars
qui subiront le tir ennemi mais qui
permettront également de détecter les
positions adverses du Hamas et donc de
les bombarder en en second en repost
finalement puis envoyer de l'artillerie
ou ou des blindés mécanisés pour
reprendre le terrain oui j'ai entendu
aussi que les les Israéliens avaient des
des des des des des bulldozer
complètement blindés pour faire ces ces
opérations ABS qui est en fait il faut
imaginer donc une grande rue une avenue
par exemple qui est jonchée de détritu
parce que les les de détritu et de de
grava merci et de grava parce que les
immeubles se sont détruits il faut
pouvoir y passer avec des blindés donc
dans ces cas-là vous lancez au début des
des gigantesques tractopeles blindé qui
vont repousser les gravas de toute façon
à pouvoir vous vous faire passer mais
encore une fois à partir du moment où
vous êtes avec cette tractopel vous êtes
exposé au feu ennemi vous êtes exposé à
de l'artillerie des roquettes des drones
c'est vraiment une opération extrêmement
périlleuse on ne voit pas comment cette
opération ne peut pas entraîner des
pertes importantes dans l'armée
israélienne oui on verra effectivement
dans les dans les prochains jours à date
il y a 169 soldats israéliens morts une
chaîne spéciale de la télévision
publique a été créée à la fois pour
donner le nom des victimes en direct
mais également pour donner le nom des
soldats tombés au combat et voilà et on
le disait il y en a aussi énormément
puisque on le voit tous ces combats tous
ces points rouges là ce sont tous les
combats qui ont eu lieu quand les quand
les quand les hommes du Hamas sont sont
arrivés il y a eu des combats
effectivement extrêmement
meurtriés dès samedis et ils ont mis du
temps aussi pour réussir à les repousser
faradza le le le le kibut dont je vous
parlais qui est sur sur votre carte qui
est l'endroit où nous avons enfin où les
Israéliens pardon l'armée israélienne a
découvert les massacres dont nous
parlions euh l'armée israélienne n'a
réussi à en reprendre complètement le
contrôle que dans la nuit de lundi à
mardi parce que les tirs de roquet
étaient trop intenses et qu'il
n'arrivaient pas à progresser dans de
des conditions suffisamment important
pour pour sécuriser le lieu il faut
imaginer que l'armée israélienne est
composée de militair d'actif mais
également énormément de pardon de de
réservistes qui ont été rappelés 360000
réservistes ont été mobilisés pour ces
opérations donc c'est absolument
considérable euh 360000 ces 360000 donc
ont été répartis certains ont été
renvoyés dans des centres d'entraînement
certains Français Clara Idalgo a publié
un excellent reportage sur le le site du
figero et elle a réussi à retrouver des
Français à roissi qui ont pu qui ont pu
partir et qui vont aller dans un centre
d'entraînement le temps de voilà d'avoir
une petite remise à niveau et enfin
certaines unités donc ont été déployé
avec leur blindé avec leur régiment et
ensuite ont été alignés le long de la
frontière de Gazin et ont pu avancer
jusqu'à créer ce fameux siège et cet
encerclement de la ville de Gaza la
question que vraiment tout le monde se
pose c'est quand les israéliens vont-ils
entrer dans la bande de Gaza et pour y
faire quoi à partir du moment où vous
êtes dans la bande de Gaza va se poser
la question au gouvernement israélien je
rappelle que le gouvernement israélien a
évacué la bande de Gaza et les colonies
en 2005 qu'allez-vous y faire est-ce que
vousz vous voulez y aller pour détruire
tous les centres de recrutement toutes
les caches d'armes du Hamas mais l'armée
israélienne a déjà conduit de telles
opérations par le passé et forcé de
constater que le Hamas se
réapprovisionne toujours combat
toujours voulez-vous couper le le pays
en deux il installer des colonies mais
mais au prix de la réprobation
internationale et d'une sécurisation de
site qui est vraiment coûteuse en homme
en matériel et en
effectif c'est vraiment très compliqué
il sauver les otages c'est l'option qui
s'offre au au gouvernement israélien
mais comment le Hamas n'a pas manifesté
de volonté de négocier ses otages c'est
vraiment extrêmement compliqué
effectivement les Israël qui se retrouve
dans dans une situation vraiment de très
compliqué pour réussir à voir ce qui se
passera pour la suite on attend on
disait une une attaque potentielle qui
pourrait arriver dans les jours à venir
mais ça peut aussi prendre beaucoup de
temps et on le disait aussi un siège
quelque chose comme ça ça peut aussi il
faut pas forcément le faire durer trop
longtemps non plus en fait je pense
qu'il y a plusieurs plusieurs choses
c'est-à-dire que un siège naturellement
va engendrer des des pertes civile dans
la population de de Gaza puisqu'il n'y
aura plus d'eau la nourriture ne sera
pas réapprovisionnée il n'y aura plus
d'électric cé moins de soins enfin des
soins médicaux dans des conditions moins
bonnes donc vous allez engendrer des des
conditions vraiment de vie terribles
mais également comme je vous le disais
les mobilisés sont des gens qui comme
vous et moi avant ce samedi-là avaient
un métier faisait tourner l'économie à
partir de quel moment peut-on continuer
à avoir des mobilisés qui étaient des
civils il y a quelques jours euh est-ce
que ça va avoir aussi un impact
économique sur la croissance israélienne
il y a aussi cette question qui se pose
là alors je pense qu'aujourd'hui elle se
pose pas dans la population israélienne
qui qui encore sous le choc des
atrocités qui ont été commises par le
Hamas et qui vraiment demande réparation
à la population Gaza et a vraiment envie
d'en finir avec ce problème terroriste
du Hamas mais à un moment force forc de
constater que les chiffres parleront et
qu'il faudra réfléchir à la à la durée
de de cette guerre et surtout je pense
que la question se posera dès que
l'armée israélienne rentrera dans la
bande de Gaza l'acceptabilité du nombre
de pertes militaires israéliennes pour
une opération militaire dans la bande de
Gaza oui effectivement ce n'est pas du
tout fini comme on le comprend bien on
avait une question de jocos alors on en
a parlé aussi un peu tout à l'heure mais
il parlait de l'Iran le rôle que peut
jouer l'Iran l'Iran qui a déjà joué un
rôle il semblerait en tout cas que c'est
eux qui
ont aidé en tout cas à à créer
cette cette attaque alors il y a il y a
des bruits qui ont circulé très
rapidement le le gouvernement iranien a
démenti le gouvernement américain
certains officiels américain pardon on
dit qu'il n'avait pas véritablement de
preuve pour relier
directement l'Iran à cette attaque du
Hamas donc à date il est très difficile
de répondre par par oui ou par non je
suis désolé jocos à cette question
néanmoins ce que l'on peut dire c'est
que le Hamas reçoit des armes des
financements et de l'entraînement
militaire de la part des Iraniens qu'
est soutenu également par le hzbolah qui
est une autre milice dont nous parlions
tout à l'heure qui est elle-même
soutenue par l'Iran donc finalement
peut-être que par
ricochet l'Iran a pu a pu jouer un rôle
mais il est en tout cas à date
impossible de dire que c'est quelqu'un
intérant qui a donné l'ordre aux
militants du Hamas d'aller attaquer au
sein de de l'État d'Israël bien merci
beaucoup amoroutané en tout cas d'avoir
été avec nous merci à vous du Figaro
d'avoir été nombreux à nous suivre on
remercie aussi le service infographie du
Figaro vous pouvezetrouver cet article
sur le site du Figaro comprendre
l'attaque du Hamas contre Israël grâce
au kartes article très intéressant fait
par Arthur bijotta ainsi que tout le
service infographie du Figaro merci une
nouvelle fois et moi je vous donne
rendez-vous dans quelques instants pour
la question du jour sur le site du
Figaro bon
après-midi